okay i
i think i'll get started now so hello
i am inveisha das and i'm currently a
senior in high school
from kanpur india um
and today i'm going to talk about
computational behavioral science more
particularly i would be concentrating on
my works
on understanding emoji usage and their
meanings behind them
um i attended the wolfram high school
summer camp in 2019
uh then i was a part of bell both from
emerging leaders program 2019 and i've
currently been an ambassador
for the welcome students group for a
couple months
so my current project actually started
at the camp
itself uh where i looked at global emoji
usage and then later after the camp i
ended up extending it onto what you're
going to see
today so with that i think
let us get started um
yeah so in today's talk i'm going to
cover
two of my studies the first one is very
similar to what i
conducted at the wolfram high school
summer camp which is i studied
general emoji usage um
now emojis have recently gained a lot of
popularity
in computer mediated communications
and the good thing about them from a
behavioral standpoint is that they have
the potential
to give really useful insight on how
public
behaves in general
they could also provide insight into um
deeper meanings of how people perceive
things etc so the first study i'm just
going to cover
um emoji usage at large so for example
what emojis are the most popular ones
that are used
or how are they distributed by
geographic area
et cetera and in the second one i'm
going to talk about a way more recent
project where i
explored how the onset of a pandemic
that is coronavirus might have affected
emoji usage
the aim with this study was that by
seeing how the emoji usage pattern
possibly shifted
we might be able to understand if there
has been a general shift in public
opinion
since the pandemic started so this could
actually act as a
really useful implicit tool to help us
understand public behavior
at large um with that i think i would go
on to talk about
a few of the general terms that you're
going to hear a lot throughout this
presentation
the first is what exactly are emojis
uh so emojis are uniqlo characters used
to depict non-linguistic expressions
like
um a smiley emoji or a heart-based emoji
i listed three of them here
so this is theories of joy emoji the
heart emoji and i think the face bombing
emoji
um now the question is why do we use
them
is that they're filled with meaning so
for example when we're
sending a text we may not know what
exact emotion we want to convey
but but an emoji can help with that
um and in this study across both of the
studies twitter was used as the platform
for updating all of the data now the
reason for that was
twitter is a microblogging platform and
that means that it allows
messages and texts of very short
character length
um which include which increases the
likelihood
of using emojis in place of long words
to express emotions
and to study behavior using emoji
twitter was a great place to start
now although there hasn't been much work
done about emoji usage in general
um they're a great tool and the question
then arises what
factors affect emoji usage
which in turn can help us understand
these factors by looking at the emoji
usage itself
so things like once age gender or
relationship type have been known to
affect emoji usage
including something called platform
diversity for example whether we are
using twitter or whether using
some sort of other social media um
here um the study covers how
initially the first one just covers
general emoji usage but in the second
one
we explore coping 19 pandemic
as a possible factor for affecting
global emoji usage um
so next i'm just going to cover the aims
for both of these studies
so the first as i have mentioned before
was done
to explore general emoji usage to set up
a baseline
we just wanted to explore what are the
dominantly popular
emojis using specific geographic
locations
and for the second hand we wanted to do
a more pinpointed approach um
we wanted to see if the number of
coronavirus cases in a specific area
might be affecting how emoji usage has
been affected in that
region um yeah so with that let's go on
to
the methodology now there were many
parts to it
so looking from the technical standpoint
that was obviously the challenge of
collecting data and then developing the
algorithm to separate out the emojis
from any given piece of text
and then the second one was what factors
do we exactly
look into so first let's cover the data
collection part as i mentioned before
both of these studies were done on
twitter databases
i will quickly go through the code that
was used here
for both of the studies primarily the
code was
very very similar so i'll just go
through one of these
um for example you can see here that i
use service connect to
connect to twitter and then i just use a
normal query search
uh filter them by location because as i
mentioned before
the goal here was to really be able to
see emoji usage by geographic locations
so we we filtered it by the geolocation
and then we
kept it at 2000 tweets per country
we had it go through all the countries
um i think there are 249
that mathematica recognizes and then
they restored onto
a local file uh what's important to
mention here
is that in two of these studies these
two data sets were
eight eight months apart so one that was
collected in june 2019 during the summer
program
and then the second was in march 2020
which was
um collected probably just a few days
after the pandemic was officially
declared so the aim was to study the
initial chakra reaction
um with that let's go on to look into
the emoji extraction
algorithm the problem here at hand was
to be able to extract emojis
from any given piece of text because
when we're obtaining the data from
twitter
it's all mixed up we really don't know
and we want to be able to select
only the emojis and be able to compute
with them
um now this was probably the most
challenging part just because
it wasn't very straightforward
fortunately people
from high school summer camp really
helped me come up with this methodology
so how it worked was we first got
the original listing of all unicodes
and then there's a specific range that
are used for emojis
specifically so then that was extracted
and then
the normal text all of it was converted
into
unicode um yet we also had to convert
between utf-16 and you give eight at
this stage which
which caught us up in the beginning um
but after we had that the task was
pretty simple the task was to match
these unicodes from the original list
onto what we had
and that is how our emoji extraction
algorithm worked so the code that you
see
here this is part for the unicode thing
so this line of code here first gets
all of the unicode data in one place
then the next
part of the codes work to select only
the unicodes that represent emojis um
the next part as i mentioned here was to
match
these two so first all of the data from
the local files that were stored were
imported into a mathematical notebook
then there were some countries that we
didn't get the data for
the query didn't work so we had to first
eliminate that
and then this code right here signifies
the imagine process
where we match our original listing
to the data that we collected um this
flow chart here
explains the general working of the
algorithm so first we obtain tweets
filtered by geotag country and then we
change it into its unicode form
that the list of unicode emojis were
obtained then they were matched
and we converted into an emoji database
by country so at this point it was ready
to be computed
and we could look into various factors
and then actually make conclusions out
of this
um so yeah this is this specifically
uh goes through the methodology that was
used for
study one and study two study one again
was pretty simple
we just used the database that we
generated before for all of the emojis
directly
i think it's study too that really
requires some clarification here
um so we wanted to look into different
factors
from the emojis that we could extract so
here we looked into three things
the emoji density which is defined as
the number of emojis
um per tweet and then
what were the popular emojis used and
what were their relative popularity but
really the popularity here we mean
what percentage of the total emojis did
this specific emoji makeup so for
example if tears of joy is the most
common emoji
then what percentage of all of the
emojis did this group
make up um now i think the reasoning
behind choosing
these factors is pretty important to
go over uh now behaviorally speaking
these factors could be loosely dubbed as
a measure for
how sufficient these emojis are for
expressing emotions in a given situation
say in the wake of epidemic do people
feel that using more emojis can make
their expressions better
or on the other end of the spectrum do
they think that such a serious situation
can't really be expressed by using
apologies
so although the emoji density might not
seem that deep of a factor
it can actually be used to predict human
behavior pretty nicely
and then comparing these specific emoji
usage before and after can give us a
further insight into
any possible differences this this on
the other hand is a pretty
direct method um
next um i'm just gonna go over the
results briefly
um so from the study one what you see
here is an emoji density heat map
um how it worked was we calculated the
emoji density
which is number of emojis per tweet
so here you can see the code we got all
of the countries sorted them out
and then this calculates the ratio which
i call here the emoji ratio
and then finally this maps out the
relative usage of emojis so for example
here i think
um usa is probably
in the middle and then i think this is
norway or sweden
they probably use the most number of
emojis per tweet so
emoji use this density was used as a
factor here
uh next going on to the specific emojis
used and the relative emojis
so across the globe um the
tears of joy emoji came out to be the
most popular one so i think out of
uh 249 around 50 so i think 102
countries had that as their most popular
emoji that was used
here we just um got all of the emojis
um sorted them out nicely and just
placed them so this was also pretty
straightforward
um now going on to the results for study
this was probably
a bit surprising because considering the
pandemic i was probably expecting we
would see
newer emojis say the microbe emoji or
um the mask emoji but what instead
happened was i didn't see much of
difference in the actual
emojis that were being used um
what i exactly mean by that is that for
example
um if tears of joy was the most common
emoji before
it still remained as this most common
emoji afterwards there actually wasn't
much of a difference
however an interesting point to note
here is that across the first
um so while we're comparing here i think
i think i should go back and mention
this is that we divided all these groups
into clusters
these countries were divided into
clusters by the number of covet cases
they had
again this was in april so for example i
think usa was
usa that was up with china back then
and so we divided into clusters and then
we wanted to see the emoji usage by the
cluster because it made sense to
correlate it with the current situation
of the pandemic
um i so yeah there were four clusters
that were
used so the first three clusters where
there were the maximum number of code
patients the related popularity of the
most popular images
uh dropped after the start of the
pandemic so that was probably the most
um
significant finding here for example in
cluster one
so the one that had usa in china at that
time the figures of
joy emoji which was the most popular
emoji across all the clusters made up
around
34.36 of all the emojis used if i'm not
wrong in the first category like before
the pandemic started whereas after the
start of the pandemic it only made up
14.69 um now this
couldn't be a coincidence because a
similar pattern was acros
like seen across cluster 2 as well where
initially the tears of joy emoji
made up 17.7 percent of all emojis uh
whereas
afterwards it only made a five percent
so i think the drop is pretty consistent
here so for example it was 35 before
dropped to 15 the second most popular
emoji dropped from 17
to 5. in even on cluster 3
um there was still a gap but the gap was
slowly closing in
and by the time we reached cluster 4 it
had almost
leveled out so as earlier mentioned
the emoji usage dropped by 75 for all
three clusters in general um
indicating that the average usage of
country emoji
which were affected by the pandemic drop
so uh it could be that
the first um thing that i mentioned when
i was talking
about the pandemic was that probably
people felt that it wasn't
sufficient to really express their
emotions at that point of time
so the pandemic might be a very serious
thing that is affecting with their
behavior and the
emojis are not really sufficient to
express that
um and then
just concluding everything um
an attempt was made to study general
emoji usage pattern throughout both
and the first one we just established
some of the most common ones that were
used
um and these could potentially act as
something
that we could use in the future to
predict public behavior
which was kind of the aim for the second
study where we wanted to explore whether
the start of the pandemic had really
affected emoji usage and whether
this change or shift in the pattern of
emoji usage could really be used to
predict
any shift in public behavior
yeah so before i go into the
acknowledgements i also briefly want to
mention
the future works that can really stem
out of this
so as i mentioned right in the start of
the talk
the factors that affect emoji usage are
not really established
so we know that a gender or somebody's
geographic location might affect but
we don't really know for sure so i think
some
really interesting lines or similar
projects could be to look at how
one's native language affects emoji
usage so for example
some countries or primarily dominant
languages
might be using pictorial representations
they might be using more emojis because
it might be sufficient to express um
the right emotion in lesser number of
characters
or another whole range of factors that
could be affecting emoji usage
is one's socio-economic factors so
stuff like gdp or their literacy rate
um they could really give an insight so
i think what i'm trying to encapsulate
throughout this presentation was really
to look at how
emoji usage for a country or different
patterns
globally could be used to reverse
engineer
the behavior patterns or how you might
expect people
to um behave in a certain condition so i
think the aim with the study was to
really look at the
other side of it um with this i would
just go on to the acknowledgement so
first off i would really like to thank
from high school summer camp
um my mentor rory there were other
mentors kyle phillips
and christian and mads i if any of you
here right now
thank you um the second study was a
spin-off to the first one and i did that
independently um i think i'll just go
and see if there are any questions
and if there are then i would take them
now
um let me figure out where bath ball is
right so i don't think there are any um
questions right of the bat but if you
have anything feel free to put that
on the chat or if there was any part you
might want me to go over again
i would be more than glad to do that
oh okay we have a question here
so okay why don't you go ahead and ask
it i just see the um
statement here but i don't really see
the question
thanks andy for joining us this was
great
uh no baby can hear you i don't think
you can be
unmuted um
or wait i i think i actually can
yeah i just oh yeah hi okay i can hear
you now it's such a cool paper an
interesting result
and um super impressed with the
creativity and also
the results are super interesting um i
guess the question that i have is
in general um when you talk about the
usage of emoji
then it's definitely highly correlated
with the usage of
uh twitter in general right like um
when people use twitter more maybe the
use of
emoji also gets higher so
in your study how do you take into
consideration of this factor
like do you treat the density and the
usage of twitter
in general as a control variable there
yeah i actually do so if you see my
biggest two factors here were
emoji density and then the related usage
which are both
uh taking into factor how many tweets or
how many emojis in general we were
collecting in the first place
uh so like i mentioned absolutely i
think in this second
slide about how different this could
absolutely vary between different
platforms
so i think the results are definitely
dependent on the platform of study that
we choose
um and twitter by just like by its
character land definitely has its
advantages and disadvantages but you
really don't make a good point here
so i tried to take in stuff that is
neutral
uh which doesn't really um
kind of take the popularity of that
platform into consideration
but then that could definitely affect
the final result
hey does it answer your questions very
helpful thank you and wish y'all all
right
thank you so much for joining me this is
great to have actual people listen to my
stuff
so um
all right wait oh thank you brenda
uh for richard yes i think i will be
providing
the notebook i might make a few changes
and i will be uploading the file
probably
by tomorrow maximum
yes the file would be available thank
you so much everybody for joining me
we have another question you think
okay now it's amy he's saying it's
interesting thank you so much amy
okay there's a question about what was
your experience at the summer school so
first of all i went to the summer camp
which is the place
for high schoolers uh it was great it
really changed how i look at computation
i didn't even code before i went there i
was just interested in math and human
behavior
and going to summer camp really added a
whole different skill set that i have
exploited if you would allow me to say
after coming back
it's been really great to be able to
integrate computation
into my interests with human behavior
and i'm really excited to see how this
goes i mean if i if i would be able to
do it again i would definitely do it
again
that was my experience at the summer
camp
all right i think i will be ending the
meeting now thank you so much again
for joining me um i would be more than
happy to answer
any of the other questions you might
have on basketball
um okay okay we have another question
let's do that beforehand this so the
emoji density map showed the highest
emoji density for kazakhstan
i wonder why that was the case and to be
honest the answer is i don't know i
think that was the aim of the study to
really understand what factors can
affect emoji usage for a different
uh geographic location and um this is
a segment i would say is not very
explored so there could be so many
factors
that play into this right now i was just
looking at
um emoji usage in general and then i
looked into covid as a possible factor
uh i have been doing the socio-economics
side of it outside of this
but there haven't been any significant
clear-cut factors that might be
affecting emoji usage so we're yet to
find out
sometimes it can be pretty erratic and
the explanation is not super clear
but i think that is the aim with the
study